こんな風に見えています
非常に視野が狭いんで歩くときとかですね
足元見て照明見て
ゆ未定
障害物とか人がいないか確認しながら歩いています
といってもですねあの白く自体は0.30.4と右たりありますので
人と接するときとかですねあの
人の目を見ながらかはわかりますし力があるんでね
人の顔見ながらコミュニケーションをとるというのは可能です
病気かというと網膜色素変性症といいます
約ね8000人に1人発症される遺伝性の病気です
さっき言った
視野が狭くなるという時と症状と
やもうと言って暗いところあの会場今こんな感じですけど僕
ほとんど見えていない状態です
暗いところ昼間はですねあの普通に生活してるんでそこまで視聴ないのかなと思います
けど
この病気
もう一つ特徴があって
将来目が見えなくなる病気ッ
言われています今残されているシェアが全部なくなっちゃって光というものを将来
なくしてしまうって言っておき
症状があります
この症状に
青春時代ですねやりたかったことだったりいろいろ甘酢ありましたけど
何かを得るたんびに
どうせ名見えなくなるからと思うと
どんどんやる気を削がれていきました夢だったりとかねやりたく
やりたかったことがあるんだけど見えなくなったら何もできないんだって思ってました
一つねあの野球がやりたい時期があって小学校5年生の頃がピークで
よく学校行く前に朝お父さんと弟とキャッチボールしていました
ボール投げるのは機内でも球投げるの大好きでした
ん
学校早く行きなさいて怒られましたけど
れねあのいったある日ですねお父さんが家の近くの少年野球チームのコツと話しつけて
くれて木刀弟2人ですね
練習参加させてもらえることになりました
夕方の5時ぐらいからですねやり始めましたけど最初ランニングして
その後2人一組でキャッチボールしていましたまだ見えます
夕方6時になりますほとんど見えなく夏相手から帰ってくる球が見えなくなっちゃって
キャッチボールができなくなっちゃいます次守備練習に入りましたセンター守ってまし
たけど
わかるのは味のほうでコーチがですね
バット6してくれる課金て弟
飛んできた球がバウンドする音しか確認できませんでした
家に帰ってお父さん1回お父さん1回だけ聞いてくれました
野球史体感
やらせてできるようっていう僕いいましたどうしても野球がやりたかったです
でも今日まで来なかっただろうと言われました
いや今日は暗かったからできなかったので朝たキャッチボールできてるじゃん
できるできないというやりとりを繰り返しているうちに僕が根負けしちゃって泣き出し
ちゃいますよくあの
目が理由で
傷ついちゃうと布団にこもって号泣することでした
号泣して
布団の中で神様によくこんなお願いしていました
僕の残りの人生半分上げていいから
明日あの普通の女ちょうだいっていうお願い事をしていました
健常者の人生ください朝起きます
そんなことないんですね何も変わらない
新対象外というのはねあの基本一生モノで
私の病気には治療法がありません
そういう傷つくことがあるたびに僕は今長めのように
薄暗い気持ちになってました
それに拍車をかけてですね高校2年生から3年生にかけて
シア外一気に狭まった時期がありますそれを機にですね
高校3年生の徳野氏の相談でお父さんがもう学校にいけばって言ってくれました
盲学校て皆さんご存じですかね
あの視覚障害者特別支援学校とも言いますけど目が悪い方でもですね
学べる環境づくりをした学習施設になります
私当時視覚障害者にこんな偏見を持っていました僕の子の目の状態でもやりたいことが
できなかったのに
全く見えてない人たちて何もできないんじゃないか隣に誰がついていてあげないと何も
できないんじゃないかと思っていました
そんな学校に通ってしまったらもう自分の視覚障害を見て見てしまうみたいで怖くて
入れませんでした
ただ
お父さんとかお母さんとかですねあの将来の私の目を気遣ってここに入れなさいと眼科
医の先生も
名見合うなくなる前に
行っとくべきだよってここであん摩マッサージ指圧師はり師きゅう師っていう
目が見えな人たちができる仕事の国家資格
向かってマッサージしんなりさなさいって言われていました
しぶしぶ入ります
いろんな方がいました
当時クラスメイトはずに言いましたけど僕がよる見えないのに対して
昼間が見えないまぶしくて見えないけど夜は大丈夫だよ石橋君よる
見えなかったら
任せてって言ってくれる人がいました
色の違いがわからない人がいました
視野はあるけど視力が0.01って方もいました
0.0値という数字初めて聞きました
中でも一人にあのびっくりしたーーーが方がいて
1人前全く見えない人がいました全盲の
お前たときから全盲だったらしいですけど
さっきねあの何か補助がないとやっていけないんじゃないかと言いましたけどその人は
校内を
普通に徘徊してました
フリーハンドで杖もつかずにまあ慣れたらあの
常なくても老化歩ける区のかなーって思ってましたけど
歩いてきて精子がいざ間にね
おはよう石橋君て行ってきました
まったく見えぬ見てないです彼を見えてるのって言いましたけど
なんでわかったかというと足音でわかるんだよっ
目が見えない彼らにとって聴覚から入る
耳から入るね情報がすべてです
足音とその人の声で判断しているよくよくねあの興味ん
すごいなぁと思っていろいろ話していたら
普段家に帰って料理もするし一人で全く見えてないですよ
あと買い物にも出かける
洗濯も身の回りのことは自分でできる会員でガンバローって売っている人でした
授業中パソコンを使っていますとめちゃくちゃ早いです
ふと自分と比較します僕当時あの
実家暮らしで家に帰ってきたら勝手にお母さんが作ってくれた
美味しいご飯が出てきます
風呂入って選択も気が向いたら行ってみますと
お母さんっていうか親に丸投げしてましたパソコンもね当時そんなに使ってなかった
から
一般平均レベル以下でしたこの時点でも完全に
人間的に負けちゃったなと思いましたん
全く目が見えてない人に
視力がまだ残ってる人が負けて当時
悔しい気持ちになりました
でもそれと同時に
たんだろう
僕の今の状態でもまだできることがあったんじゃないかってできることを探そうとして
なかったんじゃないかって気付かされました
それとねあの
全く見えてない華麗が日常生活こんなに頑張っているのを見て
将来僕も目が見えなくなっても
なんとか自分の努力次第で
身の回りのことだけはできるようになるんじゃないかという心のスキーをもらいました
カラーの
人間的に
学ばされましたいろいろ
そんな
人間性だったり視覚障害の文化だったり
を勉強しながら2年生の時あ
2年前ですね
なんとか雨マッサージ指圧はり師きゅう師の音国家資格をとって
今ヘイズキーパーって仕事をやっています
会社の中の人ヘアにペットを置いて同じ会社の人たちをマッサージして気がしてあげる
っていう
お仕事です
終わった後みんな言ってくれますありがとう気持ち良かったよ
楽になったよ
今
私はその人ほどのために
仕事が生まれています学生時代に失いかけた
やりがいだったりとかもね今実感してます転職を視覚障害からもらいました
もう一つ目ね
もらったものがあります
あの小学校1年生の時に視覚障害が分かって
それと同時に年あのお父さんにあることをやらされました
10どうやらされましたなんでかというと
目が見えなくなっても耐えられる心ハートを作って
見えなくなっても
人とか物にぶつかっても
耐えられる頑丈な身体つくりなさいと言われて柔道をやっていましたという話を当時の
盲学校の先生にしたら
石橋君しかし公害車10度てしていると視覚障害者どうしの目が二重の方同士の重度で
あるんだよって a
初めてしていますパラリンピック種目
石橋君頑張って皆様って言われて
しかし障害者柔道をやることにしました
今は強化指定選手としてヘルスキーパーの仕事で
ん
同時進行で頑張っていますパラリンピック目指しています
僕にとってパラリンピックというのはへ
[音楽]
今まで
自分の女のことで悔しい思いをした分ここでもし通常してメダル取れず
さえすれば
何だろう
視覚障害があってもよかったなって
その舞台に立てるんじゃないかって言っ
視覚障害に感謝できる日が来るんじゃないかという期待も込めて今頑張っています是非
資格証あのパラリンピックですね皆さんモニター越しにでもいいんで応援して
いただけるとありがありがたいです
教具は選べなかったかもしれません
視覚障害のことでじゃくちゃ悩みました
何もできないんじゃないかそんなことないよーともう学校に入って
できることを教えてもらいました
自分の境遇から今の現状でもできることを探してみて
そこを伸ばしていくべきなんじゃないのって気づかされました
嫌なことばっかりあったけど
そのいやのことから学んだことがたくさんありました
嫌なことの
良い面を視覚障害者たちのいいところを知らずにね
もう
自分のメディアって言っています
いざ知ってみるとやれることあるんだなって自分でも頑張れることがあるんだなって
救い
作りをもらいました
勇気をもらえました
将来目が見えなくなっても大丈夫っても
はっきり言えます
とか皆さんも自分の嫌いな部分
な部分の
ただ嫌うだけじゃなくてねあの
プラスマイナスで見てもらって
嫌いな中でも多分ポジティブな部分があると思います
そこをどうにか探してそこで初めて
好きか嫌いかというのを判断してもらいたいと思います
そこから得られる見えてくるものもあるんで是非皆さん自分の境遇
見つめ直してもらう見つめ直してください
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]